RIGHT HERE.
WATCH THIS.
YAKOV TRENIN.
TRENIN COMES IN.  ION OF HOW
BIG THIS HOCKEY GAME IS.
>>
THE PAST.
FAR SIDE. OUT
OF THE ZONE.
DALLAS IS TIEDSURE SAROS DOESN'
THAT  THROUGH COLTON  A BUNCH
OF TIMES IN THE CAMPS.
WHAT WAS YOUR FIRST  -- SHE'S 1
YEARS OLD. -- SEGUIN.
ACROSS.
THE SHOT. BLASTED.BEHIND THE NE
QUICK ONE TIMERNE CHANGE.
RATTLED OFF.
SWINGS WIDE.
CENTERS IT.
GREAT SAVE.
SAROS  TOOK 17.
EFFORT FORD FIGHTS THROUGH TWO
THERE.
PAVELSKI, IN
GOOD BODY POSITION.THE
BLOCKER SAVED THERE.
LINDELL, SNEAKING IN.
TH
LINDELL, TO
AND WITH FORSBERG.
SEGUIN  IN THE OFFENSIVE
ZONE.
PAVELSKI HANDERS ONE.
GLOVE SAVE.
FANS ARE GOING CRAZY RIGHT NOW.
APPRECIATING THE EFFORTFOR DALL
THEN, WITH HEISKANEN PICKED THE
GETS TO BENN.  ISSCROSSES.
TIME EXPIPI
EVERYBODY IS STANDING IN OSE.Wi
ROW NUMBER TWO.
FILIP FORSBERG IN D TO THE POST
FORSBERG AND OVER.
12 INCHES.
HE'S GOT A GOAL.
>> Willy: CRAFTY VETERAN.
STOPPED BY RIGHT-HAND SHOT.
LO
JOSI , SLIPPING DOWN.
KUNIN
STYMIEING THE CAPTAIN.
>> Chris: WATCH.
THERE'S THE FIG.
IN ROUND THREE.
>> Chris: WOW.
PATIENCE AND STRUCTURE.
SAROS lly: WE MOVE INTO ROUND
FOUR.
GRANDLUND, FOR THE GOLD
JERSEYS.
HE
>> Chris: